how y'all doing tired is this extra is
this extra credit work you're doing
there enough studying to do
okay after that nice introduction if
it's okay I'd like to brag a little bit
can i brag about what I have going for
myself I'm very lucky to have four very
good qualities my first is that
impressive to brag already okay my first
good quality is I'm a horrible reader to
this day I can't read well I can't spell
very well in second grade I had sister
Sheila and I had cheated in my alphabet
test and she found out I didn't know the
alphabet and I had six weeks to go in
second grade
then I flunked second grade and she had
this thing called the blue paddle and
she has paddle to hell out of me for two
years then I had to go on third grad to
go to this place on Crenshaw because at
the time my parents thought I had bad
memory
was a memory taking notes what's so
interesting what's this is just a story
there's no notes I mean I had okay I
couldn't read I went to memory school
it's what's noteworthy about that then I
went to dr. Paul and Hollywood and there
were eight kids in the class two or 18
years old I'm eight and I kept thinking
well there's something wrong with this
picture why am I in school with 18 year
olds and you could visually tell that
they had real learning issues and I kept
thinking well I must be kind of goofy
why am i that school but I I heard if
you have real severe learning problem or
problems out of the birth canal you
can't look up so I said to these guys in
the backyard I said look at that
airplane and they couldn't raise their
head and I thought wow this doesn't feel
right for me
so then I went to dr. Walton my parents
said every word I ever read cost of $50
dr. wall might have to look at these
stupid little eye circles I accept I
like my eyes and do I exercises because
at the time they thought bad reading had
my muscles I'm still at this time not
figuring out these stupid little letters
and I don't see reading in my defense I
was with my little boy here he's a
senior in high school and in second
grade he had this spelling word called
se W now what does SC w spell does that
make any sense whatsoever
why does s so SC w spell so it's not
fair I just can't figure out the stupid
code it's so should we say less oh then
I found dr. her dr. K would graduated
impressively from high school 8th from
the bottom of my class of 1200 and went
to figured out how to get there you know
I want to ask you a question this is
just an A or a B I'm out of high school
and there's a group that kind of thought
didn't reject me kind of wanted me now
it's kind of cool but this group you all
had to wear the same clothes sleep
outside be with mosquitoes and leeches
and bombs and bullets
that's decision a that's called a Armed
Forces or decision B was go to college
drink beer and flirt with women what was
a better choice okay so I figured out to
go to junior college and I went to the
USC Extension Office I do think it pays
that were at I get to know these people
so she said okay we'll let you and if
you go to extension I figured out how to
get through USC with a solid C average
and you know DS dude get degrees I have
a degree but what do you know about SC
that you guys don't have at this junior
college most what do you guys what is
sem football and what don't you know
about football players they don't
exactly ray
the curve so I figured out how to get in
their classes and I could always get to
see and I majored in loopholes like for
an example there was one night a week
there was a great place in a ticker a
literature requirement
well literature says 15 books I'm not
going to read 15 books in my lifetime so
I graduated from SC are you impressed so
far now I know your feel my hands
what do they feel like the word soft do
they feel soft that's right there are
some now I don't have any mechanical
ability I don't know how to do the 6
shift I had this business Kinkos I never
really knew how to run the machines when
I say really I don't know how to run the
machines so it was a big I don't know
how to I don't have a computer I don't
know how to fix things I'm really what
are you writing down the state okay
so I don't know how to fix anything ok
so that's a pretty good quality now my
third very good quality is I'm extremely
restless I do not know how to sit down
and why was that an advantage at Kinkos
my job at Kinkos was going store to
store at a store always looking for what
people are doing right can't you make
more money looking for ideas and you can
hovering in your office
worrying about the cost my variable cost
was 16 cents I sold it for a dollar do
you or do you think I'm going to spend
my time worrying about sales right an
idea is worth a lot of money for an
example we had a one of the stores they
did these calendars you ever seen one of
our calendars you take 12 little
pictures and you put them on a calendar
format go like this do you ever see one
of our calendars on a wall your personal
family did they ever have it you never
saw a calendar with your family honor
wait a second let's try this again if
you ever seen a calendar custom calendar
ever like oh well we do a lot of
business in calendars you know but they
cut we charge $30 they cost us two bucks
to make and we did them in December you
think that's kind of a cool business was
that idea worth a lot of money how many
hours a day can you all work in this
room let's just can you work or go to
school five hours a day put your hands
up if you can I need it I'm not getting
paid so just put your hand please okay
can you work eight hours a day twelve
fourteen sixteen eighteen twenty seven
days seven days a week 365 days a year
that's a good question
you could work like you can work like
this forever you know what does that you
know what does your savings works 24
hours a day 7 days a week doesn't it and
your ideas don't they work all night
long so wasn't my business my savings
account and my ideas so you can work a
little harder than you can with your
brawn you can work with your ideas and I
was very lucky I didn't have too many
skills I couldn't do things capably I
couldn't fill out a form and I can't fix
things the world's not going to say come
welcome you Paul to the world of
anything I've just had to work with
those two what God gave me and I was
able to have an advantage I think I was
very lucky and where my fourth good
quality comes into play does anybody
know anybody it's Lebanese in this room
do you know any Lebanese people that
have a job I never I have a Southern
California we must have three four
hundred relatives really and I never
knew a soul at my family's house had
ever had a job they always had their own
business so I was never raised with the
idea we're going to work for other
people it's just not part of the
equation
I remember wrong other you know I need
you just always have business stuff
around the house I remember going by the
Hollywood Ranch market I was a kid my
was in the backseat of the car
my mom and dad were in the front saying
out that market slope with 24 hours it
isn't that smart to spread their
overhead 24 hours it's just the whole
the way your Araiza was always business
parables and the way my family
approached education was I believe you
go to school to learn and I think it our
families my parents house you always had
interesting conversations they involve
the world current events and they were
always engaged in society and you're
going to think this is a very goofy
story
my brother was studying at 9:30 at night
once my dad walked in and said what are
you doing he said well I'm studying for
a test and my dad said you'll never
remember it so what's the good of
learning it the idea was you go to
school to learn you're going to use this
stuff in real life
there is always a conversation and
relate what you learned in school to the
real life so whatever you think you're
taking down on notes and forgetting you
know when they said subchapter S in your
business school did you have to take
notes on that couldn't you remember I
save a layer of taxes on that when the
guy said 3 X 3 y and organizational
behavior do you think I'm going to use
that I'm gonna have my own business one
day when the guy said LIFO on FIFO I was
saying yeah that's kind of cool I'm
gonna be unlife oh let's save on taxes
but I didn't have to take notes on this
it was just I knew I was going to do for
a living so what you're learning in the
school my business school I mean I
learned and I already applied it in the
class I use the most in my entire life
was microeconomics and at the time you
think what goofy class YZ curves those
nonsense but it really was the class I
used the most because everything I did
in my business was all marginal revenue
marginal cost you know it cost me 16
cents I sold it for a dollar so if I had
a worker and they used to think we're
the greatest thing since sliced bread
and I can't tell you when you come from
a family where you have in workers how
important your responsibility to them is
you have a lot my dad I only time I ever
saw him come home with the problems when
he had to fire somebody I was just you
know you you have empathy for your
workers I guess so the workers at Kinkos
used to think we were the nicest human
beings because we had free lunch on
Fridays allegedly free lunch okay it
cost two dollars to buy the lunch on
Fridays which was the duct wait let's
try this again what's the most precious
word I had in my parents house the
business word I heard constantly I just
said it a secretary it's deductible
didn't my parents always say it's a duck
table there's not a common thing so if
it cost me two bucks to buy the lunch
what does it cost to write the check so
the workers can get two dollars you know
they have all these little low
governmental clubs that just want to
take all the money from the workers so
it cost me three dollars to write a
check I could write to my workers for
two dollars in it now the income taxes
if I save two dollars the income tax
guys say well let's take 90 cents it out
away so it cost me a buck ten our cost
of workers three dollars we was that
kind of a good deal so I figured it this
way if it cost me a hundred dollars to
employ somebody why not spend the five
extra dollars and get that attitude out
of them right didn't it make sense
we had a daycare we had a program where
we would put money in tax deductible and
would go out tax-free to our workers
children for college education that kind
of cool deal and what do I want what's
my motivation
it Kinko's I want long-term
relationships with my workers they
didn't give to it so damn about the
customers didn't care about Kinkos they
cared about Joe Blow that always works
that it does my job so I want to keep
people with us we had a program to help
with down payments of the home now was I
being altruistic or as I being shrewd I
would seek the supposition I was
probably being shrewd I never felt I was
going to work to be altruistic I was
always a conniving little cunning part
of me Sam I think this might make more
money right does it make sense to spend
the five dollars extra now if you know
it what I've already told you I get
extremely restless what is my favorite
job at Kinkos to do I like leaving the
store I hated those stores I didn't like
being in them I just didn't like them so
I was always leaving now you have two
choices when you leave your business or
you treat workers this way
go like this now anybody who's ever had
a job which I never really had but it's
an employee always have the last laugh
you go like this to a worker what do
they do back the hit you ten times
harder is that common sense you've been
mistreated hahaha I control the cash
going on until I can give bad customer
service I could contaminate other people
with lies about the owners and you think
you're the boss baloney though
workers are the boss if you're the good
owner you realize your workers are God
you're there to just do anything you can
to make them happy so does it make sense
to go like this with a worker or like
this do you get the idea happy fingers
will ring happy registers so I got that
one really quickly wasn't really hard
where I was very once again very lucky
with my skill sets in life as I knew I
couldn't do it better than anybody else
my model has always been anybody else
can do it better and in my case am I
correct
anybody else could basically do it
better than I can
I can't write a letter I know I'm really
good at one thing I'm really good at
getting out of work
I had one store I had 10 50 100 but I'm
really good at getting out of work I'm
not good at getting I don't like work I
don't like it so you like my skill sets
now my biggest challenge and you might
want to examine yourself on this
challenge
everybody in this room I'm pretty sure
you are very compulsive hard-working
people you wouldn't be here is that fair
to say when I started when we started
our business we had three workers in a
store the leader of the store was what
knew everything about things didn't they
they were very compulsive knew all about
everything contrast that to the Kinkos
that I left 40 and 50 workers a day 40
50 workers open 24 hours a day
what was the skill sets of the leaders
of the business that I left I know about
how to manage people I don't know a lot
about things we started with people that
knew a lot about things we evolved to a
business that knew how to manage people
now my supposition is with you all if
you can't let go and you'd like to be in
charge of things
don't try to lead people you'll have a
nervous breakdown but if you can handle
ambiguity that people make mistakes have
your own business but don't try to be a
leader if you're not cut out for it
you'll really have a nervous breakdown
what did I write that was so interesting
then really what did you write you have
to write a paper in this really I love
the fact that you're right right and
paper and all that I just don't see what
I said that was our shattering that's
flattering that you'd like to take notes
it's all in this book you could read it
now I want to tell you an observation I
have about you all MBAs and I think what
we've done in life with you all is if
your child comes to home with a painting
from school what do you say to him
absolutely the worst thing you can say
is saying that to a child that's a
beautiful painting you know why you want
to tell the child tell me about the
painting and why did you do it because
what we do with children from the very
beginning so we teach them they have to
please others rather please themselves
my supposition is that you all because
you got here and been good about
defining yourself by others rules I mean
obviously if you went out of high school
and got a job for two million dollars a
year you wouldn't be back you're getting
MBA you're probably your supposition is
school make me successful and and school
has an obligation to keep you busy 80
hours a week or you wouldn't want to pay
the tuition but my supposition could be
that that idea of being so busy is
sabotaging your anxiety and you need
your anxiety you have every reason well
they always give you this bogus reason
about the economy but I think that's a
bunch of baloney but they'll give you
all these reasons why you have to be
busy but really I think that idea of
anxiety is okay to have do you think
that anxiety and ambition are best
friends and if you're so busy how in the
hell can you ever have time for anxiety
is the whole miserable nature inside
your stomach the stuff that's going to
propel you and is your busyness your
friend or your enemy it's the fact that
you are a miserable person when you go
to bed at night because you're worried
going to help you in life yes it will
I promise you if you if you go to your
anxiety side you will be much more
successful in life you'll start noticing
you'll start noticing things here who
may who's been to Berkeley okay have you
ever seen a place called top dog what
did you notice about top dog
okay we're an entrepreneurial class what
did you notice yeah they have a lot of
people online
did you ever calculate the charge five
bucks a customer six bucks a customer
they can do three a minute what does it
caught at two workers what does it cost
you to make a hot dog
fifty cents you sell it for three or
four bucks what a little glass of coke
cost nothing do you think you could say
well I think that what do you think is a
business didn't did you notice how
successful that was was that screaming
success to you every second you were
there or you just buy on hot dogs
do you keep your eyes open and say god
there's people online why are they
online what's their margins how come up
what's the barrier entry now ever I had
my own business Kinkos Here I am all
across the country with all the
enlightened business students like you
all and all you had to do is notice all
my customers in line it's a stupid
little Xerox machine you plug in and you
rank a cash register how hard was it you
go like this you dial a button and then
ring a register why didn't I have more
competition if it was your grandparents
generation would you have had more
competition
hell yes what is it about your education
that keeps you from seeing what's right
in front of you a top dog do you want to
wear the suit and tie and pay all that
income tax or have capital gains and
subchapter S income maybe you'll open a
top dog and not be so highfalutin that
place is successful the most successful
book ever written is the Yellow Pages
they wouldn't be in the yellow pages
that they weren't successful you're
surrounded by success thinking about a
washing machine washing machine weighs
maybe 150 pounds you buy it for $750
isn't that an amazing thing five dollars
a pound you get all those little parts
it suddenly seems to break and that kind
of amazing thing how you get that whole
washing machine for five bucks a pound
and that kind of cool deal are you aware
that you are surrounded by success every
time you're buying something is a
successful endeavor do you see the
success around you are you obsessed with
making money from the success around you
are you obsessed with what's wrong like
you could sit in your office and now
you'll have a great cop up the economy's
bad and I'm not going to get a job well
tough you've got that cop out for
the rest of your life
that's not going to be if you want to
have that you could intellectually be
very honest and you could sit at the
Oasis and just become an alcoholic
I mean reading you have that
intellectual option because you see the
job markets bad I'm just going to go to
depression isn't that fair that's an
honest response and I would say maybe
you ought to just think about all the
gifts you have and say the world is
successful I want to be part of it but I
don't want to work for other people
maybe that's I think why you're here is
that right well let's try to save your
money you might have more opportunity
duh get a good night's sleep do you know
the secret elixir of life is sleep
everyone wants us natural everything why
she's track good night's sleep for a
change
you know what you've learned in the day
time is imprinted on your brain while
you sleep so if you're not getting a
good night's sleep you're not taking
advantage of your education my mom only
cared about two things saving and
sleeping well it's the only two things I
don't care what you're doing you're
going to bed early and you're getting a
good night's sleep your grades aren't as
important as a good night's sleep
that's just chief wasn't a big believer
that you're going to go to all of us
went to college you know why my mom why
we all went to college because it was
fun not because we learned a hell of a
lot in school because we applied it to
real life so maybe your straight A's and
all that stuff is really your enemy
maybe your compulsion and being judged
by others is your enemy and the only
real success you'll ever have in life is
how you feel about yourself so it's the
real battle inside here I'm going to
illustrate it with one last anecdote
you're going to fall in love one day
with somebody and you're going to love
them here but you're not going to love
them here what happens you get a
stomachache here don't you you fall in
love with somebody here you don't love
him here what happens you get a
stomachache here where do you follow
love with your stomach
are you cultivating your intuition and I
would say if you're not drinking enough
beer at the Oasis you're not taking
advantage of your education because what
you're going to do in life is you're
always going to be gauging people if
their BSS or not if you're not
cultivating your human skills they're
going to snow you you know what I mean
drinking beer is not your enemy drinking
beer and socializing having coffee
you're learning that those are very
constructive moments you're learning is
that a person a BS are going to trust
them what is the behavior that I really
want for my workers I would say that a
lot of your education might not be it
might be 80% of what you can learn in
the school is going to be outside the
classroom and you've got to take
advantage of all the clues you've got to
be in the moment the see opportunity if
you're preoccupied and busy you're not
going to see like I saw I was lucky
enough to make the Xerox copies I saw
people in line I saw him I was lucky
enough to see top dog see the customers
align I was lucky I was never I was are
looking for opportunity because why I
couldn't do things capably myself you
right now I'm not capable okay what's I
just think just so baffling what you're
writing it could be so astoundingly
complicated that are you going to look
at these notes ever in your lifetime you
never look at these notes why don't you
just be with me in the conversation
that's I won't let my like I tell you a
story I ask to have it I know how to get
out of work I used to work with this
lady and she knew how to these
scribbling letters you know this for
shorthand and I said look I'm not
effective here I don't utter don't take
what I'm saying here here's my problem
here's the letter I have to responder
now you figure out how to put it on a
piece of paper isn't that a lot easier
way getting out of work well if you want
to write dictate every little comma and
punctuation point you might not be
getting the big picture okay I am done
with my editorializing did you
when I asked me what my past my mom said
I said put your hand up and say God she
gave me some great advice she said in
your 20s honey try it all in your 30s
figure out what you do best
40s make money from what you do best and
your 50s don't do too much be like uncle
Nick and uncle Amal you know there they
had money saved they were bartenders
from the war they saved their money
bought bars and they bought real estate
and in their 50s their big decision was
where are we going to go eat lunch today
you want to live like that I did I sold
my business I was 50 I didn't want to
have the stress of 22,000 workers on I
was 50 but also your business is an
instrument to make you happy it you own
it it doesn't own you and men make a
mistake more than women of defining
themselves by their career so I don't
think yes I experienced what you enabled
your employees to feel by being a very
frequent Kinkos customer before the
acquisition and then after FedEx
acquired them I saw the change in the
employee attitude
you have any comments well I have a been
in a store since I sold it and I used to
have kinky here that was the name of the
business was my nickname kinko and prior
to being kinko my nickname was pube head
so but it's a you know organizational
behavior when they have Theory X Theory
why they imposed a theory X culture on a
three-y organization because everything
we did was customized but everything
they do is sort of not too creative so
they try to put a command and control
structure on a creative business it was
a total mismatch from they want and you
know it comes from there your education
once again you Stanford folks you guys
go to school I was always lucky you go
to school you have your own elitist
little class rooms you're gifted if you
go to your little groups that are so
much more gift you go to AP classes then
you get to go to those ëletís little
high school classes then you go to your
leaders universities where I was always
lucky as always with the dummies here
I always thought these guys I was more
skeptical you know suspicious of these
guys than these guys we think these guys
have come up here they say wow I don't
trust the rabble they're just they can't
manage themselves I was very lucky I
always knew that I was already
suspicious of the executives I was never
suspicious of the workers so look at the
yeah I sold the business those jerks
from New York
I should have known they didn't get it
because I I remember they wanted to CEO
the new CEO I was pushing some little
place in the claws over in the side and
I was just too earthy for these
establishment people and the guy wanted
to have you know I had very my spans of
control I had everybody accountable I
could point fingers at at cost centers
up the Gazoo we had to have four layers
we had regional manager area manager
division manager than the CEO I had
three you know the Catholic Church
pretty good order they've been around a
while
Cardinal Pope we had to have four so I
was there at the end the guy wanted to
get a co o because managing three people
was to ownerís
and the office so I I was making an
issue of the lines of spans of control
and they came from the retail background
where they worked at Walmart and this
thing called Kohl's department stores
and all that so they were you know I was
in the side of the table and they were
intellectually discussing where you put
the merchandisers in the organizational
chart
have you been to a Kinkos do they have
or do they have merchandise we don't
have merchandise we're a service
business I can't sell yesterday's hour
in my machine I can only sell today and
tomorrow can I can I say yesterday's
hours wasn't I in the time rental
machine rental business I have a bowling
alley isn't that the same thing can I
say yesterday's time in my bowling alley
I'm in the time rental business these
guys thought it was the merchandising
business if you have merchandise can you
sell it tomorrow yeah it doesn't
self-destruct your clothes and the rack
so mismatched
they put a thing culture on a idea
business I couldn't work there anymore
they were so stupid you want another
great stupid story
we got this McKinsey you ever heard of
McKinsey are they here or something so I
leave the company they spent two million
dollars to study our business okay I was
at this I was talking to this man and he
owned these markets called sheets as
markets in Pennsylvania you ever seen
him okay guy tells me at lunch you know
I can't explain it but we would close
our business from midnight to 6:00 in
the morning
and because we'd only do $40 in business
but our daytime business would drop and
a half he said I don't understand why
just closing those six hours would have
such an effect on my daytime business
what the guy said tell you I go to bed I
like to sleep two days later I wake up
like a bat out of hell I said what did I
tell you if you go 24 hours a day your
daytime business doubles is that correct
and it's true it doubled my overhead was
the same everything it was all marginal
profit was that a cool discovery
let's go like this yeah it was a good
discovery so the bozos get this McKinsey
in there and McKinsey takes the
stopwatch and says by the way you'll
save a bunch of money closing at 10:00
at night and opening up at 6:00 in the
morning was that the wrong decision you
know the art of business has seen what
isn't there anybody can see what's there
but the art isn't seeing what isn't
there did anybody see the half the
customers I lost because I wasn't there
but that's that's another thing that
maybe you guys don't see is you don't
see what isn't there maybe you should go
home and have some more anxiety you like
my story so far did you expect me to
come along and applaud your straight A's
do you love accounting it's the best
class you'll ever take whatever you do
they make it too complicated
do you like okay you are you in business
are you entrepreneurs do you like money
it's all about counting money how do you
not like accounting it's the best class
I loved it
I've really loved to kill me I loved
economics I loved organizations behavior
like marketing I didn't like the goofy
math courses oh the quantitative
analysis and all that any City purpose
for it
okay you have another question yes no
there are different kinds of people you
know this I don't I got out of the
giving I just give the money if out
giving money is actually a little bit of
work because once you start giving to
like the starving people in Somalia or
someplace you never stop giving to
everything disbursed
my heartstrings go out to single mothers
because I think I don't see how the hell
they right now in society how they you
know he pay him next to nothing I don't
see how they could possibly do anything
in life and I think that giving up I saw
my wife what she did to have her that
children it just seems like you need a
lot of help raising children and the
single mothers just seem like they need
a lot of help in society so we do
everything with children we try to or
trying to change the way people eat in
schools as a relationship believe it or
not between nutrition this is an
astounding concept and students learning
I could just hit their school I
anonymously gave string cheese at
breaktime
the kids loved it do you think that they
have protein in the morning they might
be more receptive in fourth period like
the Lions they like to be they train
them after they're fed so I like the
nutrition were involved with I don't
know what else were involved with but we
have a lot but we want to focus and we
say no and no quickly I'll tell you that
in business and as much as I get bug I
can say no as quick as any human being
on earth because you don't string the
other guy on some people just don't know
how to say no and they get a lot of
extra work it's very respectful to say
no I'm not interested this is not what I
do and charity if you allow people to
you know you give to stuff you're not
focused on don't bug the hell are you so
we are very good about focusing on what
we do best and we're going to spend more
money on fewer things yeah yep yep
so question around execution obviously
you say that there's no one else you
know and in your grandfather's age there
would've been a lot more competition how
did you keep people out of the market
you know it's a average idea that you
executed fantastic okay I did okay it
could have made more but do you know the
four PS of marketing what are they so
I'm glad you remembered your education
how many people take a marketing close
don't remember that a lot when I started
my business I sold Xerox copies for
three cents a copy what was my utility
price contrast that to what's the
utility of Kinkos that I left eight
years ago was it price it was it was
product an array of product in a
synergistic non-threatening manner
most businesses never like Costco could
really never go up market to Nordstrom's
or McDonald's can't go up market to some
fancy restaurant right most businesses
that start with price can't go up market
I was able to and I was a deliberate
plan I didn't I always wanted to I liked
businesses that you can always raise
prices for an example look at Dell
computer not good they take a big rocket
scientist to say whoa I think computers
always go down in price and I got to do
more to the product to make myself
viable like duh is that I mean is that
an astounding concept look at Wrigley's
gum I don't have to do anything to
redesign it and I can always raise
prices which is a better business but if
I go to the cocktail party and all these
highfalutin people say oh I just bought
EMC squared I saw it on the free well
what they'll it does or I bought JDS
unifies all these intellectual men while
sit around and say what did you buy Paul
I like tootsie roll
and I like Wrigley's gum I'm just maybe
I'm just stupid but those are the simple
businesses I like I like a business that
you can raise prices the customers don't
mind it when you do that's kind of an
easy business to make money that is hold
us back and I think it's great the way
that you sort of come to this piece with
your weakness and I'm just wondering
what was the journey between you know
like the recognition that you had this
thing and then using it now to impact
people in such a positive way oh I was
fair I take a lot of anxiety seriously I
was know I felt like a dumb my
whole my life I really did I was in high
school I didn't you know they're really
good I think business will maybe you
know what Bob Hope said when you're 20
you care what people think about you
when you're 40 you don't really care you
think they'll think about you then you
get to be 60 you realize no one ever
thought II in the first place
what is but I think everybody's
miserable their 20s aren't they they're
all defining themselves by others I
think I probably just as much if not
more as anybody else yeah I didn't have
a lot of success as a child you
understand I wasn't really court going
out of their way to compliment me yeah
you know but my parents they never they
were always in my corner and I think if
my mom wasn't that wasn't on my side I
think I would have easily been defeated
you know I mean I should never I never
felt I never had the luxury being stupid
around the house there's a lot of single
store successful there they're doing
well they never go beyond what I was
very lucky is well first of all I like
cash I really do and I know how to do my
cash flows and we're a subchapter as a
private business when I tell you that
was the hardest thing to pay the income
taxes and manage my cash I enjoyed it
the most was the most challenging what I
had going for me as I could tell from
the very beginning a customer walks in
they don't know what the hell they want
and they want it yesterday is that fair
to say they're uptight and confused so
they walk in and they talked to a worker
the worker is it kind of a junior person
in society but there's a bank president
or some professor the worker can suggest
I mean they feel kind of cool suggesting
to somebody important in society the
worker sees the manufacturing process
and sees the smile at the end all right
that was a self fulfilling business I
didn't have to get involved with you
follow me I could only screw it up and
my wife gave me the best definition of
management management is to remove
obstacles my whole job was to make that
job that relationship better does it
make sense for a boss to say let's go
out and burden the workers so they can
more unproductive my whole job was to
make they had a problem at home anything
I wanted their lives
easy and it was a self manageable
business so I could leave that business
and I was able to have my proclivity not
to work very hard most I had 10 hours a
week of stuff I had to do the other time
I was wandering and getting information
I also had a business I didn't have to
the filthiest dirtiest obscene word and
businesses inventory because I was in a
vegetable business in college my
inventory rotted overnight my dad made
women's clothes over time it rotted I
mean he went out of style I didn't have
any inventory I had a fight
I was threatened time so in that regard
I was able to leave my business and have
a bird's-eye view and I didn't have to
if you fight in your inventory I
couldn't I'd have to be there all the
time making sure that they weren't
stealing it or that they were
merchandising property I didn't have a
problem with that
I was lucky so my business I could
really it went to my skill sets I would
never go on a business that had
inventory I never have I gave
notoriously yeah I remember when I was
your rock scene at the first store I
kept saying to myself if I don't do
something to get out of here when these
kids these kids children go to college I
say go go see Paul he did my Xerox
copies
I just didn't want that but the hardest
thing for me to manage was to in three
stores because what happens is the owner
or a leader you become very meddlesome
and I remember talking to my bookkeeper
and I said seven stores she said you
know you're losing your effectiveness
you're talking to your people too often
so there's a fine line have mettlesome
when you're the owner because every time
I went in there I destroyed the morale
of the manager by being meddlesome so
there's a fine line you know how to
trust people and verify was it it was it
but I was lucky I didn't like the
business you understand I liked the
money I was in it for the money I don't
like reading what would I care about
your Xerox copies for it didn't interest
me in the least I understand it wasn't
like oh I love to Xerox I love computers
I love all the stuff that they do I just
didn't have any aptitude for I didn't I
didn't like the written word really I
don't know I was in the written word I
made money from words and I hated them
yes oh very easy I think the world is so
interesting just the very interest I'm
curious i taiked teach in school I teach
at Loyola
I'm my own classic everybody A's top of
25 years well i reaiiy don't believe in
grades i think it's their impediment I
won't let my students take notes and I
pick on them all the time and they have
to be current they can go to Santa
Barbara for four years and never say a
word in class so I I like teaching and I
like I like the whole world's
interesting you read yesterday about was
intrigued by calcium they said calcium
and adult people prevents cancer so I
was intrigued by that intrigued by how
long your hair grows why does the head
in your here always seem to grow and
none of the other hair seems to grow I'm
just foolin I just
but I get to think about what I want you
know what's nice about my job now I get
to wake up every day thinking about what
I want to think about and I like my
thoughts I don't like waking up and I
was 40 and I was in the middle of
business I didn't I had bad gas
I never slept and I had a neck ache now
my neck doesn't hurt no gas I sleep like
a baby I didn't really it's nice if I
like being interested it's a very
interesting world so why does you know I
was reading about these little things
about cells yesterday do you like to do
New York Times thing when they talk
about science why the cell some cells
turn off and become liver cells and the
some sort of it's just interesting the
whole thing's interesting yes
what's your view on business in the
future
with respect to sustainability oh and
running out resources or water how does
that work within workers in terms of
flattening them I think that so much
opportunity in that business we had the
Industrial Revolution the information
revolution we're going to have a green
revolution we better get on board
plastic bottles are terrible I think the
whole opportunity is now redesigning all
of our homes efficiently insulation I
could just these stupid lightbulbs you
have here seriously as a whole area of
opportunity in that whole field you know
for an example the federal government
motivates you to buy solar panels but if
I'm a Stanford University why would I
put a solar panel I don't get it I don't
pay taxes to begin one what's my
advantage so why is there a way to
figure out how to finance solar panels
in this green stuff I mean as a mortgage
holder landlord wanna fix his what but
he wants to put it on the mortgage maybe
they could figure out a way to rent the
roof I don't know but there's a lot of
this whole world has changed so quickly
in this one I get involved in that one
it is yes
oh I like your questions why do you sit
the front row are you a student or your
teacher or your teeth oh front row I
never sat in the front row I just
already said thank you okay yeah oh man
you want my theories my first theory was
ugly women work harder wrong
then I really did I have the curl I had
to go out pass out flyers and staple
things and she came back complain about
her feet and all that so I got rid of
that theory then I had Jesus freaks
wrong then I just went for normal
Republicans and Democrats and I started
to manage the environment better but
normal people are great but then I not
tell you that best way to spot a phony
I'm Catholic so but if they start
bringing up this like choir practice
Thursday nights in the first 20 minutes
of conversation don't trust them because
those are the people trying to tell you
I'm religious therefore you could trust
me wrong don't try those are people rip
me off the most the ones that bring up
their religion in the first 20 minutes
as if that's going to build my trust in
them that's a big red flag yeah ok you
want to hear my theory of how I hired
people I'd like I take him out drinking
I would and I want to see how they were
nice is what they were like when they
were drinking there's some truth to that
and I'd like to see I like noticed how
they how they were if they were
courteous to the waiters and waitresses
and somehow I'd always asked last
Christmas would you do and if they
didn't go to their parents house they
went skiing or something I wouldn't work
with them because to me that's just a
sign that you're good you go home for
the holidays that's just a big sign for
me that if you're not many thoughtful to
your parents you're not gonna be
thoughtful to me
and our credit when I left our business
of the 200 most senior people we only
had eight divorces not my credit but
that seemed to be a good thing and you
can pry about Christmas in the interview
if you do it over a dinner table what'd
you do last Thanksgiving camera what are
you going to do oh I'm not going to
drive my parents house in LA I'm just
going to stay here and do so from Santa
Barbara I just seemed like that was his
lame excuse
you have to like your parents you know I
keep hearing she's not gonna like me
yeah I like school okay I actually
enjoyed school because I went to learn
and I didn't care about the stupid
grades but I really did learn and I
enjoyed every class if I bothered
learning that I remembered it and I
really did enjoy but I didn't want to
read because I couldn't do it very well
why because I saw people online xeroxing
and I thought this is a good business
that there's xeroxing at USC at the
four-year school
why wouldn't they Xerox at Santa Barbara
like I went up to this junior college
and I had a Xerox place you guys are
rocks pretty good you know junior
University
we don't have junior and our diplomas
but we have football teams yeah so
that's how I just saw people online do
you think garbage collectors really love
garbage do you think a guy says I really
want to go out and make do garbage as
you think it's really cool you could do
stuff that just for the money yes I
really agree with a lot of what you said
about having too many skills and too
much knowledge gets in the way of doing
the important things um so I was
thinking about you know how how do I
deal with my kids and how would I deal
with the people that I work with and
then I was thinking well how about at
GSB you know how do you deal as us to be
able to teach people to not allow their
strengths to get in the way of doing
what is really critical for success
that's a problem I don't you know what
there's no playbook for it how do you
you know what's cool is when you get to
be oh when I they say people with
dyslexia I went to Harvard and this guy
was talking about people with dyslexia
people with dyslexia feel comfortable
with ambiguity I was always comfortable
with ambiguity and you know when you're
a parent if you're too strict in your
teenagers they become wimps but if
you're too too loose they become drug
addicts where's the fine line no but
really when you when you when it's when
you have a baby it's pretty simple you
put a bottle in your mouth or change
their diapers it's though ambiguity
there but raise a teenager is very
ambiguous and I think of my career the
ambiguity was what drove me nuts I mean
I had to come to grips with the fact
that whatever came to my attention was
ambiguous and I remember I talked to
this guy and he said there's this book
call in search of excellence and there's
a whole chapter of an ambiguity I did
read the chapter and this people can't
figure out if electrons the protons are
energy or matter
I figured if these physicists can't
figure that they said in the book they
can't figure out the basic thing in life
if it's energy or matter its ambiguous I
thought well hell if I came to grips
with the fact that life's ambiguous I'm
not going to make good decisions all the
time but you have to come to grips with
that you have your own business you got
to come to grips yes one more
enters and that kind of stuff throughout
your life oh you just get it what my
uncles and everybody in my family
old people like to see young people
succeed so if you ask him questions
which I was always good at I was very
good at asking questions
I was generally I was always interested
in what they had to say so it wasn't
hard to find mentors and I was always
alert and my family I mean I was very
impressed with my uncle's in the way our
family will operate it you know Lebanese
I think they've been beating the hell
out of by everybody everybody seems to
invade him all the time so I think I was
raised where you know you have a
business but it's about enjoying your
family you know you don't want to really
go on the Rules Committee of the
government because just sell him stuff
don't don't worry about how the
government does stuff that's the way I
was raised but I really was raised where
they had a good good split between their
business and who they are in a imagine
there's two circles these Venn diagrams
remember that in eighth grade the circle
here and a circle here well when you're
in business those things overlap were
you and your business they don't have
them they're all you know overlap I was
always good because there was kinko here
and there was Paul here and they were
totally different circles and I was very
intentional about them and the only
thing I did capably in my life was
Kinkos I could have easily been seduced
by this person but I never really wanted
to be seduced by what my perception of
what kinko was and I already made a
conscious effort I really fundamentally
believed that if I had I wouldn't have
made good business decisions because you
can't fall in love too much with your
own business you got her I would never
sold it you know it's your business you
got never could forget what you wanted
in life like I get more joy out of that
guy with little cap there
let me tell you a funny story about
Keenan are you embarrassed
we'll get up and say something look so I
would say I did in one day
Keenan you're not getting an inheritance
you got a work work work work there's
not a dime for you you've got a work
work work work work so he says you know
dad I don't want anything from you but
when you die put it put a ATM in your
graveside and give me the code that was
him right there there's only one measure
of success in life you know that is your
children want to be with you and they're
adults that's the only measure of
success you could have all his fancy
stuff cars all that nonsense but you're
alone on the holidays that's a
loneliness
so just remember what successful in life
and we used to have it can I say one
more thing I'm going over my time you
find me that captivating
you tube three minutes is that okay
because I'm a ham do you remember I told
you we had to go from a thing based
culture to a people based culture we had
to incorporate in the philosophy of our
company the values the real value
statement of what we're all about the
idea of work love and play to be
successful in life
you have to have three things in balance
if not how would you run a 24-hour day
business if you didn't have a balance in
your life you follow me I mean to have a
nervous breakdown if you're just a
workaholic wouldn't you so I think to be
successfully have to have all three and
you'll be more successful if you strive
for balance in your life
you make better decisions
somehow wives really ground the hell out
of you you're not a big shot at home and
it's good so just try to remember make
goals every year for all three work love
and play and it's not that I know it's
just important you make better decisions
you mansion when I went out and I told
these people that love things
let's go 24 hours a day what they would
say to me Paul
I can't work any harder does it how do
you expect me to keep this thing open 24
hours a day those are the wrong people
they had a idea of going to people base
people and you can't lead other people
unless you manage yourself if you don't
look rested nobody wants to follow a
leader that's tired Haggard and
miserable I mean it's just not a
prerequisite for leadership nobody wants
to I think Obama's at a bad job the
first month he looked too dour
I agree with voted for him but I agree
with Bill Clinton he is not yesterday
was inspirational but you don't want the
President of the United States and if
you don't pass this legislation you're
go off the cliff wrong he's got to
always be cheerful always uplifting
that's what leaders are supposed to do
and then somebody said well you don't
want it you want to be honest no you
don't always have to be
Seletar you could honestly say I know
this problems over there but we're still
going to charge forward you don't have
to your leadership is a different thing
it's not you openko Mona every time
remember remember work love and play
you'll be successful you'll be a better
leader you'll be alone or balanced
person and people will respect you more
so all you workaholics drink some beer